يوم صعب اخر في مصر مع خروج الالاف الى
الشوارع مطالبين باعاده محمد مرسي مؤيدون
الاخوان المسلمين بداوا بمظاهرات سلميه
سرعان ما شابه عنف باشتباكات بينهم وبين
قوات الامن وانصار الحكومه المؤقته رغم ان
مطالبات الاخوان المسلمين تبدو صرخات دون
رجع صدى حتى الساعه تبقى هذه الجماعه مصره
على الاستمرار في تظاهراتها اليوميه حاليا
هدات الاوضاع في البلد ولكن الهدوء لن
يستمر فسوف يحتفل المصريون بالذكرى
الاربعين منذ حرب 73 مع اسرائيل وكلا
الطرفين مؤيدوا ومعارضوا مرسي وجه الدعوه
للقيام بمسيرات في ميدان التحرير التي قد
تؤدي الى انف قاتل كما ان الاسبوع الاتي
هو ايضا ذكرى المئه يوم منذ ازاحه مرسي
التي تسببت بمظاهرات داميه ودعا الاخوان
للتظاهر بهذه المناسبه